Narrator: This is the climax
of the opening car chase
in "No Time To Die."
To pull this off with hardly any CGI,
the Bond crew had to figure out
how to imitate bullet impacts
and then line each one up with
the car's prop machine guns.
Chris Corbould: I think the
beauty of this sequence is
it is probably 95% for real.
Narrator: And that's just one element
of an opening sequence that involved
10 versions of the Aston Martin,
hundreds of fake bullets,
and 8,400 gallons of soda.
Here's how they did it.
As soon as director Cary
Fukunaga found Matera, Italy,
he knew the claustrophobic
paths and steep slopes
were the perfect place
to put 007 in peril.
We went out to Matera
probably 13, 14 times,
finding locations, dreaming up ideas.
Narrator: That's Chris Corbould,
special effects and car
supervisor for "No Time To Die."
While Corbould has overseen tank chases
and record-shattering explosions
for the Bond franchise,
this shoot presented a
surprising challenge:
cobblestone streets.
Matera's ancient streets weren't suitable
for vehicles going 80 miles per hour.
While beautiful, the
roads were also slippery,
with less traction compared
to modern asphalt roads.
So stunt coordinator Lee Morrison
came up with an unusual solution.
Soda.
He sprayed 8,400 gallons of
sugary soda on the cobblestone.
Once dried, the sugar made
the surface extremely sticky,
giving the tires much better grip.
The drivers could then
make sharp turns, drift,
and go up narrow corridors.
I was skeptical at first myself about it,
but when I saw it,
it absolutely paid dividends.
Narrator: Once the roads
were suitable for driving,
Bond could ride on a motorcycle
and execute a daring jump
to reach the town square.
The memorable moment was
done without a green screen.
Craig's stunt double had
to jump a 25-foot ramp
going exactly 60 miles per hour
and then drop down 12
feet onto the road above.
To hide the ramp,
filmmakers added this arch
as a clever VFX cover.
After four takes, they
had the shot they needed.
The next part of the chase
sees Bond hop in his Aston Martin,
but the crew couldn't use
just one car for this.
They alternated between 10
versions depending on the shot.
Two of them were the real
version, used for beauty shots.
The rest were replicas.
Two had driving pods on the roof,
so a stunt driver could
drive at high speeds
while the cameras captured
Daniel Craig pretending to steer;
four were driven by stunt
drivers inside the car
for exterior shots;
and two had all the
gadgets built into them.
One such gadget was the mine dispenser,
which Bond activates here,
causing this black car to flip.
In reality, those mines
were made with rubber,
and these simulated explosions
were electrical charges set to go off
as the car drove over them.
The flip provided another issue.
Because the car was going so fast,
it couldn't be attached to a fixed point,
so cables, which were usually
effective, weren't an option.
So the crew needed a different approach
to flip the car without losing speed.
They placed a nitrogen cannon
facing down under the driver's side.
When activated with the push of a button,
it lifted the car into the air.
The stunt coordinator wanted to keep it
a bit more realistic
and have it look like it was
just lifting up onto its side.
Narrator: But a dangerous stunt like this
meant they had to protect
not only the stunt driver,
but also the city's old buildings.
Corbould: Some of those buildings
are over 1,000 years old.
And Bond has a history
and prides themselves
on not damaging anywhere they go.
Narrator: So they padded the buildings
with protective concrete barriers,
dressed up by the art department
to look just like the
existing architecture.
This layer of protection
was especially crucial
for one of the sequence's biggest moments,
where Bond does a full doughnut in the DB5
while firing the car's
headlight machine guns.
The mechanics of the revolving ones
gave us a huge amount of
firepower for the bullet impacts.
Narrator: Each bullet impact
had to be synchronized
with the exact spot
the guns were pointing.
The effects team couldn't
be off by even a second,
or they'd risk ruining the illusion.
First, they used a line
lock on the car's brakes,
which helped keep the doughnuts
consistent for each take.
The stunt car's hydraulic hand brake
locked off the car's left front wheel.
Once the driver released the brake,
the car could spin on its own.
It's almost like a pivot.
So when you press the
throttle to the floor,
you're actually pivoting around
that wheel that's locked off.
Narrator: The car also had to move
in sync with the gunfire.
Corbould: We had a line where we knew
the guns were lined up,
and we knew that it took
one and a half seconds
to get from there to the next segment.
Narrator: So Corbould planted squibs
simulating bullet impacts
all around the square.
Each of these was
attached to a firing box.
Because they were set
to an automated timer,
the devices would fire only
when perfectly lined up
where the guns pointed.
Meanwhile, the stunts and effects team
had to ensure the safety of
the actors and stunt drivers.
Right before going into doughnut mode,
Craig and Léa Seydoux had to be seen
from the inside of the car
as the DB5 got shot up.
So Corbould fired about
200 pellets at the windows.
Each fake bullet created
a bullet-hole-like
shape before shattering,
and the car's windows were layered
with a strong plastic
called polycarbonate.
It would break the glass,
but there was certainly no way
that it would get through the plastic.
Narrator: While that was happening,
a crew member vibrated the
car in sync with each impact.
Finally, there was the
Connery-era smoke screen,
which Bond employs to make a getaway.
The screen needed to
let off way more smoke
than an actual car exhaust.
So Corbould took off the car's exhaust
and replaced it with injectors
used to make smoke effects in movies.
We're using the heat
coming out of the engine
to make the smoke in the exhaust.
Narrator: Funnily
enough, these final shots
of Bond and Madeleine speeding away
were filmed before any of the
preceding action was shot.
The last thing that we wanted to do
was lose one of our cars in
the first part of the sequence,
because you never know how
many you're going to use up.
Narrator: So they ended
up faking the damage.
First, the crew put vinyl wraps on the car
and scratched them up.
Then a mixture of glue,
glitter, and glass shards
created the illusion of bullet holes.
Corbould: If you got
really up close to them,
you could probably see
that they weren't real.
But, you know, the speed
they were going at,
they held up perfectly.
Narrator: All of this work was done
for just the beginning of the movie,
showing just a sliver of how much thought
goes into a James Bond stunt --
and how much soda, too.